c'est le visage de l'institution
judiciaire face aux attentats
terroristes françois molins ancien
procureur de paris aujourd'hui procureur
général à la cour de cassation le
parrain cette année de la rentrée
solennelle de la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques de l'ue vs qu
objectifs de son déplacement faire le
lien entre l'université et l'institution
judiciaire puis partager son expérience
c'est vrai que dans le cadre une affaire
terroriste il ya un besoin
particulièrement fort et
particulièrement pressante de la part de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens que
quelqu'un vienne effectivement expliquer
ce qui s'est passé et pu se dire les
choses en les nommant et en expliquant
ce qui s'est passé de façon plus
objective possible sans porter de
jugement de valeur et en donnant tous
les éléments possibles sur le sur l'état
des investigations respect du code de
procédure pénale de l'éthique et de la
déontologie juridique des principes
enseignés à lui vs cul pour la rentrée
solennelle tous les étudiants sont
rassemblées pour honorer les quelques 50
major de chaque promotion ça représente
la concrétisation de deux mais trois
années de licence et enfin j'ai enfin
réussi à
monter les grades et voilà la récompense
de tout le travail fourni
ça fait vraiment plaisir c'est en tout
cas valoriser l'excellence au sein de
l'université c'est notre recherche la
particularité de l'université c'est
d'adosser la formation de nos étudiants
à la recherche puisque le sol
enseignants-chercheurs et c'est cela qui
assure la qualité des enseignements que
nous dispensons plusieurs disciplines
sont proposées à lui vs qu entre droit
privé droit public un parcours
international ou encore une filière de
sciences politiques d enseignement
juridique est essentielle pour former
les futurs juristes
alors ce pote du droit pénal on pense
souvent à lui en premier mais c'est pas
que du droit pénal
il ya toute une dimension de droit privé
à travers du droit civil droit
commercial droit social donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui renvoie à de
l'étendue de toutes les connaissances
qu'on peut acquérir quand on vient dans
une université comme versailles saint
quentin en yvelines près de 2500
étudiants sont inscrits cette année à la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques à lui les est ce qu un
effectif en constante augmentation
chaque année